y
[Música]
rusia utiliza los alimentos como un arma
contra ucrania según lo denunció el
secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken él afirmó que las tropas rusas
tienen como rehenes a los suministros e
impiden las exportaciones de granos por
otro lado el senado estadounidense
aprobó un nuevo paquete por 40 mil
millones de dólares para ucrania
continúa el debate por la cumbre de las
américas que se hará en eeuu méxico
afirmó que espera una respuesta de joe
valdez ante la posible ausencia de cuba
venezuela y nicaragua mientras que
managua pidió que el que califica de
imperialismo deje en paz al gobierno de
daniel ortega analizaremos en minutos
y 37 años después de la masacre de
accomarca en perú fueron entregados los
restos de las víctimas en 1985 militares
mataron a unas 71 personas después de
acusar las de pertenecer al grupo armado
sendero luminoso muchos de los
perpetradores siguen libres
bienvenidos a las noticias aquí en
france 24 mi nombre es maría clara calle
y es un placer acompañarlos
y comenzamos con la actualidad en
washington en eeuu en donde el senado
aprobó el paquete por 40.000 millones de
dólares en ayuda para ucrania con 86
votos a favor y tan solo 11 en contra
los legisladores aprobaron la propuesta
hecha por el gobierno del presidente
young bite en esta misma ya había sido
aprobada la semana pasada por la cámara
de representantes
con esta doble aprobación el proyecto ya
tiene luz verde para ser ejecutado y de
estos 40 mil millones de dólares un poco
más de la mitad es decir unos 24.000
millones serán destinados para
armamentos y equipos militares para las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas otros 9 mil
millones irán destinados al gobierno de
kiev y una partida de 5 mil millones
será para ayuda alimentaria a los países
que dependen de la producción de los
granos ucranianos que debido al
conflicto no han sido exportados lo que
ha causado escasez y desabastecimiento
en algunos mercados
el propósito de este último tema el
gobierno de eeuu acusó a rusia de
utilizar el suministro de alimentos como
arma de guerra contra la población
ucraniana anthony blinken el secretario
de estado del país norteamericano
presentó la acusación ante el pleno del
consejo de seguridad de la onu lynn él
afirmó que moscú tiene como rehenes el
suministro de alimentos de millones de
ucranianos y también de varias personas
alrededor del mundo el secretario
también le pidió a los representantes
rusos que levanten el bloqueo de los
puertos ucranianos desde donde se
exportan granos como el trigo y es que
de hecho tanto rusia como ucrania
producen casi un tercio del trigo que se
consume en todo el mundo escuchemos a
blick
y
la federación rusa afirma falsamente que
las sanciones de la comunidad
internacional son las culpables del
empeoramiento de la crisis alimentaria
mundial
las sanciones no están bloqueando los
puertos del mar negro atrapando barcos
llenos de alimentos y destruyendo las
carreteras y vías férreas de ucrania
sino rusia las sanciones no están
vaciando los silos de granos ucranianos
y el robo de equipos agrícolas
ucranianos rusia lo está haciendo las
sanciones no impiden que rusia exporta
alimentos y fertilizantes las sanciones
impuestas por eeuu y muchos otros países
incluyen deliberadamente la exclusión de
alimentos fertilizantes y semillas de
rúsia
seeds formaciòn y seguimos en washington
porque allí se reunieron la primera
ministra de suecia magdalena anderson el
presidente finlandés saúl y nihilista el
mandatario estadounidense joe biden el
tema central del encuentro fue la
adhesión a la otan de los dos países
nórdicos y es que el ingreso de estos
estados debe ser aprobado de manera
unánime por todos los integrantes de la
alianza militar el problema es que
turquía ya sea o puesto y espera
negociar con estocolmo y helsinki
concesiones de armas para ankara y
también que ambas naciones rechacen al
pkk el partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán aquí les contamos
una visita en la casa blanca que podría
ser preámbulo de una nueva era
estratégica para la otan el presidente
de finlandia saúl y ninis pto y la
primera ministra sueca magdalena
anderson se reunieron con el presidente
joe biden de gira tras entregar sus
solicitudes para entrar en la alianza
atlántica en rayas azules que el
agresión james de sobre la agresión rusa
a gran escala contra un vecino soberano
y democrático fue un momento decisivo
para suecia y mi gobierno ha llegado a
la conclusión de que la seguridad del
pueblo sueco estará mejor protegida
dentro de la alianza de la otan
una decisión aplaudida por el mandatario
estadounidense
y hoy me enorgullece asegurarles que
cuentan con el respaldo total total y
completo de los eeuu de américa hoy mi
administración está presentando el
congreso de eeuu informes sobre la
atención al otan de ambos países para
que el senado pueda pasar rápidamente a
asesorar y consentir el tratado pero es
necesario que los 30 aliados de la otan
den el sí y turquía lanzó su veto
argumentando que éstos protegen
terroristas los nórdicos están abiertos
al diálogo
como aliados de la otan nos
comprometeremos con la seguridad de
turquía al igual que turquía se
comprometerá con nuestra seguridad nos
tomamos el terrorismo en serio el futuro
geoestratégico de suecia de finlandia
está ligado al de los kurdos de turquía
y siria según ankara protegen a miembros
del pkk el partido de los trabajadores
del kurdistán declarado como terrorista
por turquía y las jbg filias del pkk en
el norte de siria y aliado de eeuu en la
lucha contra el estado islámico ankara
estaría condicionando su veto a
concesiones sobre este tema y también ha
hablado sobre el embargo de armas de
ambos países tras la ofensiva turca
sobre el norte de siria en 2019
el ministerio de defensa ruso afirmó que
al menos unos mil setecientos treinta
soldados ucranianos se rindieron ellos
estaban en la planta de as hostal
ubicada en el puerto de mariupol los
rostros de estos prisioneros de guerra
fueron difuminados en las imágenes
difundidas por rusia en las que
supuestamente
en buenas condiciones a soft al se
convirtió en el símbolo de la
resistencia ucraniana en todo el mundo
estas imágenes fueron difundidas por el
ministerio de defensa ruso el vídeo
muestra la supuesta rendición de los
combatientes ucranianos que estaban
atrincherados en la planta de 'las
hostal en mariupol varias decenas de
hombres son registrados sin violencia se
les confiscan los documentos de
identidad antes de subir a los autobuses
la propaganda rusa presenta a estos
hombres como miembros del batallón a
soft combatientes del ejército ucraniano
en los últimos 24 horas 771 combatientes
del regimiento nacionalista a soft se
han rendido en la acería soft al de
mariupol en total desde el 16 de mayo se
han rendido en 1730 militantes de los
cuales 80 están heridos según moscú los
heridos están siendo atendidos y los
otros también serían tratados bien al
menos estos dicen estos testimonios
editados y difundidos por rusia
las condiciones de detención son más que
aceptables hay colchones mantas la
comida es correcta hay suficiente para
comer las condiciones son buenas
los heridos graves fueron evacuados y
cuando pregunte me aseguraron que todo
estaba bien que sus vendas fueron
cambiadas así que espero que esto
continúe
es imposible saber si estos hombres
están declarando voluntariamente ni es
posible saber dónde están detenidos
algunos han sido enviados a rusia otros
a la región separatista del donbass por
lo tanto su destino sigue siendo
desconocido por el momento se han
revelado pocos detalles sobre el acuerdo
del 16 de mayo entre kiev y moscú que
condujo a la rendición de los
combatientes ucrania espera que sus
hombres sean objeto de un intercambio de
prisioneros
a menos de tres semanas de la cumbre de
las américas en eeuu las ausencias
siguen generando debate y es que aunque
no ha enviado las invitaciones oficiales
washington anunció que no tiene la
intención de invitar a cuba nicaragua
nicaragua ni a venezuela por
considerarlos no democráticos los
presidentes de méxico bolivia y
guatemala replicaron que tampoco irán a
los ángeles y hoy andrés manuel lópez
obrador afirmó que espera una respuesta
de joe biden mientras que la
vicepresidenta de nicaragua rosario
murillo le pidió a lo que llamo países
imperialistas que dejen en paz a su
gobierno desde washington nos acompaña
amauri mayer vicepresidenta para los
programas de hbo la señora mayer
bienvenida a france24
diplomáticamente que tanto afecta a eeuu
si seis o más gobiernos del continente
no asisten a la cumbre que está
organizando
y ciertamente sería un impacto para eeuu
porque la cumbre debe ser un encuentro
entre la mayor parte de los países de
las américas entonces entre más y más
países y sobre todo países claves como
mexico deciden no mandar un jefe de
estado y hace ver eeuu más débil y ponen
en duda que tanto podrían lograr en la
cumbre misma y en medio del debate en el
senado estadounidense se presentó un
proyecto para que el gobierno de ese
país coopere con la oea para mejorar la
integridad de los procesos electorales
en américa y así resguardar la
democracia según dice explícitamente el
texto explícanos qué significa esto en
la práctica y qué tanto podría dividir a
la región si eeuu tuviera ese papel
especialmente teniendo en cuenta la
colaboración de la inteligencia
estadounidense en golpes de estado en
américa latina'
yo creo que el record de eeuu interno
electoral en frente de la oea ha sido
mixto y ciertamente a veces más con
tintes políticos esto es gran reto para
eeuu hacia el futuro es asegurar que sea
neutral y promover incluso entre la oea
que cualquier observación electoral
cualquier conclusión que tiene enfrente
elecciones sea con base en evidencia
este firme sobre resultados electorales
y hablemos del papel de méxico cuyo
aliado más importante en materia
económica es precisamente eeuu entonces
porque andrés manuel lópez obrador
decidió iniciar esta suerte de boicot en
contra de la cumbre de las américas
porque desde la perspectiva del operador
una cumbre debe incluir a todos los
países e incluye una cuba y este esto es
su idea de solidaridad y que tendrían
que incluir a todos y no excluir
entonces esto es su postura como se
comentó anteriormente están en espera
méxico- de la decisión de eeuu de quien
invita y también creo que es importante
resaltar que incluso al méxico aun si no
va al observador seguiría su ministro de
las exteriores marcelo ebrad o así es
tal como usted lo menciona a marcelo
ebrad si asistiría según dijo lópez
obrador que todo este debate se ha
mencionado múltiples veces la carta
democrática interamericana que es y como
está relacionada con la cumbre de las
américas
pues la carta fue una declaración
regional frente a valores democráticos
en logrado un mandato de crear la carta
en el tercer cumbre de las américas hace
ya más de 20 años entonces lo que ha
sido una base de cómo colaborar que es
tan extendida que reconoce los países de
favor de la democracia y de respetar
normas democráticas procesos electorales
que ahorita está mucha la democracia en
sí en muchas presiones en la región un
declive en el apoyo a la democracia y
varios países con más tendencias
autoritarios justamente por eso creo que
es importante que la cumbre misma sea un
espacio para discutir la democracia como
avanzar en la democracia como promoverlo
en países que tienen estas tendencias no
democrático mauri mayer gracias por
estar con nosotros
y pasamos a otras noticias porque cerca
de 37 años pasaron para que los
familiares de las víctimas de una de las
masacres más dolorosas de perú pudieran
recuperar los restos de sus seres
queridos hablamos de la masacre de
accomarca ocurrida el 14 de agosto de
1985 cuando unas 71 personas fueron
asesinadas por militares entre las
víctimas había 23 menores de edad todos
ellos fueron acusados falsamente por
militares peruanos de pertenecer al
grupo terrorista sendero luminoso los
uniformados los mataron y en 2016 los
crímenes perpetrados fueron reconocidos
pero quienes los cometieron aún siguen
libres
les ha costado casi 40 años pero algunas
familias peruanas lograron recuperar los
restos de sus seres queridos víctimas de
la masacre de accomarca cuando en 1985
el ejército mató prácticamente a la
aldea entera tras acusarlos de
pertenecer al grupo terrorista sendero
luminoso con sus restos dentro de
pequeños ataúdes blancos' teófila ochoa
da el último adiós a su madre y a sus
cinco hermanos el dolor de tu corazón
jamás se va a borrar se va a doler si a
mi madre no me traería vive a mis
hermanos a disipó decorar pero no porque
hay un dolor por haber perdido mis
familiares sí que sé que he encontrado
sí sí que lo voy a enterrar sí pero las
heridas nunca se va a borrar porque está
acá ella se salvó al salir corriendo al
campo pero la mayoría de los habitantes
de accomarca no corrieron la misma
suerte cuando los militares dirigidos
por el subteniente telmo hurtado
entraron en el pueblo el 14 de agosto de
1985 y asesinaron a sus habitantes
los 20 niños
ellos pensaron que los terroristas matan
ese tiempo a los niños niños niños
también nos respetaban
hasta el 2002 la justicia peruana no
comenzó a investigar la matanza para
después condenar a una decena de
militares como autores mediatos o
materiales del crimen ahora las familias
de los fallecidos planean darles
sepultura el viernes en la aldea rodeada
de pinos y eucaliptos con la intención
de cerrar ese capítulo horrible de sus
vidas
sigan con nosotros
[Música]